hello and welcome to this video play
ancient from South Africa what am I
going to play let's do something else
that is Sicilian last game maybe let's
try some fianchetto a defense here just
something else d 6 g 6 that's already
hmm so anyway to exploit this like some
see five or so probably not well here
I'm trying to see five if he takes it
clean 85 check oh really I don't know
this this looks kind of vulnerable the
center
but should be five check I can even go
knight c6 like a d5 Queen a five chick
hmm doesn't look so easy for him now to
to keep everything in order here 926 mmm
it's also d 5 which is quite reasonable
now yeah but it's somewhat this is a
lame move somehow let's do this
yeah there's some pressure on the forum
yeah okay if I take f3 now is this T for
hanging or it's probably somewhat
dangerous it's probably dangerous but
it's kind of consistent writer so he
wants to keep this pawn which on
understand very well I wonder I wonder I
wonder likely 6pm e65 or so looks a bit
strange maybe he can go d5 know himself
the shaky position for black I'm not
very much used to this kind of this kind
of setup and you know d5 looks dangerous
okay doesn't do it I can somehow block
him on the light squares this is
probably quite reasonable yeah even f5
now comes into consideration just
blocking everything yeah let's do it hey
that's a Ted conservative but okay so
let's put this on
and I is taking quite a bit of time yeah
this is good news funny thing is this
has some resemblance to nim's ooh Indian
themes just with the memory mirror image
with double F porns and white black
Michael Knight h5 Bishop nana is an
interesting question where do I go now
he's got night b5 also here there are
other gulps to the queenside 95 looks
dangerous okay yeah I don't know this is
not sure this is dangerous as h5 stuff
Jeff
still feels quite resilient yeah look to
g8 i guess i'm not getting checkmated
I'm okay which you can probably that you
can probably say about quite a number of
positions got a bit more time that's
good Jim push-up h4 it's a good idea
however this is giving up d for so when
we're not very likely to be successful
ok so this get gets traded as well so
now the g6 porn shouldn't be that weak
anymore and if I get Queens off I'm very
okay that I can actually play against
this week pawns twin 2 h8 is my point I
mean I'm not better or anything but at
least I can do things well I'm not in
danger here so I am how to do this
probably need be 5 or night can also put
the night on c4 maybe start with this
doesn't really do much no it doesn't do
anything actually I came let's go back
how to do this I can maybe try to put
some more pressure on deform with the
bishop coming around to be six
the other night not quite sure what the
other night should do they cannot do
much maybe I can go to age 7 and play g5
because he has a has some problems to
cover stuff ok that's not good I would
like you for that you can really just
take it Knight takes d5 here is a poem I
want to trade more night over to see
five maybe six was probably not
necessary if I go pawn to f4 I'm going
to win this in five part I think yeah
I'm going to win it
white resigns yeah tough game um yet our
chances here definitely not sure not
sure what I did wrong I think this this
looks a little bit questionable I
believe a wide somehow I know maybe i
should actually do this to that I
thought of but i am still didn't play I
thought yeah it wasn't I don't like
those completely blocked positions I
thought this is a little bit more
interesting but it seems to be trickier
even give 5 as a move him and he thought
I can take but the engine is very
merciless you know ok I do this and it
looks bad ok yes sir my opening here was
very questionable and also he I'm in
some trouble if he calls d 5 i'm very
sure yeah the engine could put confirms
that yeah was to do this weird but
probably strong yeah now he had stuff
like f 5m busting open the position so
now it was all or closed yeah of course
i can go to age 5 but this felt too
passive to me I wanted to do this but
here I don't know it might be that Jack
he had some chances now computer loves
white anyway but I'm not totally sure
about what is the thing here and wants
to go Bishop to d3 what is the big
problem I mean I understand that this
looks a little bit funky but I mean
it'll not getting checkmated white can
never be better with this structure is
so blocked
ook ook here yeah I mean it later hey it
looks it looks bad but I'm not sure how
bad it is I mean Bishop g7 if I can try
the rukon so I'm ok I'm absolutely not
shown in the way it was here with the
route trade I'm ok and after queens are
traded mmhmm yeah I can can play and try
things without risking anything ever
this and now yeah or he already g5 was
an interesting move because after the
capture this is very strong I didn't see
that ello it is g5 idea he blundered
this he has to play Bishop g5 maybe yeah
after which I probably don't have much
such just equal ish yeah but he
blundered this probably also i'm
influenced by the time i was a little
bit ahead on the clock Jenna here whiter
yeah why'd we lose another pawn 85 here
yeah okay a good game by ancient but he
probably time trouble induced didn't see
that 95 home capture them okay well
thanks for watching